Ok, Ok
Donc je dors pas
Quelle heure il est ?
Non regarde pas!
Voilà, j'aurais pas dû regarder
Bon allez, on se concentre, on se calme et on pense à un truc cool
La stagiaire
Elle est quand même bonne la stagiaire
Non mais ça se dit pas, ça
Bon en même temps on s'en fout, personne m'entend
Ok, je suis seul avec elle au bureau
Salut, moi c'est... c'est Thomas
Enchantée, moi c'est Emma
Sinon on baise direct
Mais pourquoi je pense à ça ?
C'était bien comme situation, c'était calme...
On apprenait à faire connaissance...
C'est le frigo qu'on entend ?
Mais on s'en fout de ça
Non, ce qu'il faut, c'est se concentrer sur une situation romantique
(gémissements)
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fout là cette affiche ?
Ah mais c'est pas celle que j'ai vue hier chez le coiffeur ?
Mais c'est pas le moment de penser à ça
Ca devait être pour du savon
Tais-toi !
Ou du shampoing...
Allez hein ? On arrête, on se calme et on pense à la stagiaire...
- Et on la baise !
Ta gueule !
- Et heu... du coup, ça fait longtemps que tu travailles ici ?
- Ouais ! J'ai commencé comme toi, stagiaire au début puis ...
(Voix extérieur) - Oh la la ! La drague nulle
- Tu veux pas arrêter ?
(Voix extérieur) - Eh ! Tu veux pas imaginer la réaction des gens à ton enterrement ?
- Non non mais tu te tais vraiment, tu dis plus rien, tu me laisses tranquille, ok ?
(Voix extérieur) - Ah ouais, je vois...
En fait, t'es amoureux
- Quoi ? -Quoi ? - Quoi ?
Non mais n'importe quoi, je suis pas amoureux
(Voix extérieur) - Ben en attendant, t'arrives pas à penser à autre chose
- Ben en attendant, j'arrive pas à dormir parce que tu veux pas la boucler !
- Chut ! - Quoi ?
(Voix extérieur) - T'entends ? Le coeur, il bat vachement vite, c'est la preuve que t'es amoureux
- Tu crois ?
(Voix extérieur) - Non non je déconne, c'est parce qu'il reste deux heures à dormir
- Eh ben tu la fermes alors !
Ouf... Allez... Calme-toi...
Euh... Tu sais Emma ?
En fait je voulais te dire un truc mais c'est un peu spécial
- J't'écoute
Voilà...
(Voix extérieur) - "Shampoui-doux", c'était "Shampoui-doux" la marque
"Shampoui-doux, tu frottes, ça mousse et c'est tout doux"
*écho
- Mais c'est de la merde que je vais te faire bouffer si tu la fermes pas
(Voix extérieur) - Je m'engueule moi-même, ça n'a aucun sens
- Tais-toi, tais-toi, tais-toi et laisse moi m'endormir !
(Voix extérieur) - Parce que tu crois que tu vas t'endormir en pensant à Emma
Comme c'est mignon
- Je sais pas mais je vais m'endormir si tu la fermes
Alors je vais te trouver et te fermer ta gueule !
(Voix extérieur) - Où tu comptes me trouver comment ?
-T'es ma conscience abruti
Je t'imagine où je veux
(Voix extérieur) - Alors trouve-moi !
(voix)
- Ferme-la !
(Voix extérieur) - Oh c'est marrant quand je m'énerve, je monte dans les aigus
(voix)
- Oh... On dirait que tu m'as trouvé
- T'sais quoi ? J'en ai vraiment marre d'entendre ta voix
- Non, c'est pas ta voix, c'est ma voix ou notre voix
- Ohhh ! Je m'avance dans la pièce et me fais face
C'est une situation que j'avais jamais vécu
- Soit tu te tais maintenant et me laisses dormir
- Soit je te fais taire par la force ! (ensemble)
(rire)
- T'es devenu complètement taré
- Nuance... NOUS sommes en train de délirer!
Alors ? Qu'est-ce que t'attends pour me faire taire ?
Tu as des doutes ?
Mais attention ! T'as intérêt à rester concentré si tu veux m'atteindre !
Est-ce que j'ai fermé la porte d'entrée ?
(voix)
"Sampoui-doux"... Il me reste combien de temps à dormir ?!
J'adore cette situation mais c'est pas sûr que t'arrives à me frapper
(musique douce)
(sonnerie du réveil)
(Musique "Shampoui-doux")